my name is Chloe Cole and I am a 17 year
old d-transitioner from the Central
Valley I was medically transitioned from
ages 13 to 16. my parents took me to a
therapist who affirmed my male identity
and the therapist did not care about
causality or encouraged me to learn to
be comfortable with my body
he brushed off my parents concerns about
the efficacy of hormones puberty
blockers and surgeries my parents were
given the threat of suicide as a reason
to move me forward in my transition
my endocrinologist after two or three
appointments put me on puberty blockers
and injectable testosterone I was
unknowingly physically cutting off my
true self from my body irreversibly and
painfully
I will never be able to breastfeed a
child I had blood clots in my urine I am
unable to fully empty my bladder I do
not yet know if I am capable of hearing
a child to full term
children cannot consent vote no on SB
107 California as a state wants to be
able to take children away from their
parents wants to be able to mutilate
children that's what California wants to
do